with the same values as me
i previously mentioned
i would want someone with a strong work
ethic for sure that's
very important to me
and someone intelligent so that when we
marry i feel comfortable submitting
because i trust the judgment
and what do you offer your ideal partner
i know how to cook i know how to clean
i love children
i love to garden as well
so
i could make
basically we wouldn't have to worry on a
grocery store because like
i'm my own grocery store
um
i would say i'm a good friend my friends
say that i listen very well and
i'm very supportive of the people i care
about
okay what about you so i look for
someone that's um hard working ambitious
a go-getter someone that's a family man
um
someone that's
you know loving
takes care of me is very supportive
and what i often return is i'm very
supportive
um
i get my own money
and
i could be a good i'll be a good wife
and you know take care of the kids cook
clean you know i can do it oh i'm good
in the bedroom you know i got the full
package
okay go ahead um
for me
i love a family man i'm someone that's
very caring supportive
um someone that takes his time to
understand me
um and also like i can have like very
good conversations with and is also
ambitious for me
um
[Music]
i am i know that i'm very opinionated um
so like that can come with a bit of you
know arguments whatever here and there
but like i'm a very like family
orientated person like i love children i
have younger siblings which like um
taking care of them as well as like um
being very driven and motivated but also
you know wanting wanting to have a
family okay what do you think
well first and foremost i look for
honesty
which is not easy
um
i'm
i mean obviously you know my stage of
life things are slightly different but
um
you know in general i'm looking for
somebody to uh to grow old with
um which is quite you know i think
everybody should be looking for that um
um
yeah so honestly honesty
intelligence integrity
and um
yeah that's about it really and what do
you offer your ideal partner what do i
offer uh stability protection
um
i think those are you know two of the
most important things and
yeah and
you know i'll try to understand them
as much as they'll allow me i think
that's
you know that's a
that's what we tend to do we do try to
understand them
as much as they allow us to
okay
um i want a best friend someone that
knows how to listen and understand me
communicate a good communicator
um
someone that respects their family and
respects others as well
[Music]
yeah just someone that's confident and
that's funny as well and what i offer
i'm very motivating i'm a good listener
i can do all the housework that's not a
problem
um
yeah just someone that's going to be
like your ride or die
um
personally for me a submissive woman
that's going to get on my program
obviously
respectful
and uh
yeah it just has molds and some values
that we can actually correlate now what
i'm going to offer is my she's going to
enter into my world because she's going
to enter into my lifestyle
she's going she's going to have
emotional stability oh yeah i'm she's
going to be she's going to feel
secure exactly she's going to feel
secure and safe what lifestyle does she
get
if i become if i make it she go she's
going to have fun she's coming where
she's coming with me she's entering my
wall what does she get like does she get
any bags she wants i need
what about like vacations of course okay
okay but no bags
listen
i want to get specific if she's a
submissive woman that's getting on my
program then i will get you it
occasionally you tell me yo does she get
like a woman's version of loyalty as
well what do you mean so
leave by her that's it no cheating no
nothing
now listen i get carried
now
if let's say that person becomes the one
percent
she's just gonna have to deal with a guy
that's gonna have options it's just what
it is bo because if let's
you're not gonna come across this guy
ever in your [ __ ] life bro so
either you go get in her program getting
his program or you go because there's
going to be other options that's going
to replace take your position
fill me here does that not mean you're
dating down not really
because if you're in the one percent of
men and you're extremely desirable
and then you have a one percent like if
you're if you're in a one percent
and she doesn't have options than she
would be you would be dating down then
by the way no a woman
what do you mean by options because if
you're dating a one percent woman let's
just say you're a one percent man
and you're dating a one percent woman
she would have options as well
personally for me i wouldn't date a one
percent woman i'll date a regular woman
i'm talking from what men look for in
women
of one percent woman
a lot of guys what what is it that guys
look for what what is it
like purity youth submission submissive
like if she was top one percent in all
those categories would you still maybe
not too young you know
i mean nothing crazy it gets sticky
because she has her own in it so even if
you cheat she can cheat or leave it
don't matter because
she has like the same level but
personally for me i would never get in a
little for girls on the same level as me
all right so i understand the question
i would not cheat on her if she was
everything like if if this was like the
one percent girl so loyalty uh
submission
everything i could think of and she's a
one percenter then i'm thinking
i wouldn't risk losing
that woman
that would be my mindset don't get me
wrong i don't know what
how life would turn out for me i don't
know if i accidentally
slip and fall
but yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't risk it
typically in relationships partners only
satisfy or meet the criteria of 80 of
what the person wants
so a lot of the times people cheat
thinking
oh like this person has 20 has the 20
that i'm looking for that i wish she had
and they leave the 80 percent for that
twenty percent
so
also i have a question so do you guys
think that cheating is morally okay
no
um
but he's bad but he's gonna
if i'm not in a committed relationship
options is widely available for sure
yeah but if i'm i mean if i'm in a
relationship with a girl
i'm not going to cheat on you if i'm
going to cheat on you i'm going to let
you know first again
like if you're on some if you're on some
[ __ ] like let's say you're holding
sex with me
i'm going to tell you okay if you're not
going to give me what i want i'm going
to go for the other girl that's going to
give me exactly what i want but would
you stay in the relationship
i mean it depends on in a period of time
for men and for women
so like a man cheating is like him
buying another girl house
or a woman cheating it's her it's her
sleeping with someone else
yes so i understand that men are
biologically different
men i mean they're wired to kind of sow
their seed i understand that it's not in
their nature to be monogamous but that
doesn't mean it's beneficial for them
and their family and society as a whole
no i agree with you i don't i don't
condone cheating but i just think it's
like if you find a one percent guy
like it's like okay i don't feel bad for
nba wives that get cheated on what do
you think
yeah like you know what i mean so i
think the point is like if a guy has
like all of the things that women want
it's not likely that he's going to be
faithful and a lot like and i think
because i kind of come from a christian
like background too